[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORGE CUETO: Thank
you, everyone,
for coming to our Talks
at Google event today
with Tina Sharkey.
It's great to have you, Tina.
TINA SHARKEY: So
psyched to be here.
And we brought Brandless snacks.
So if you're on the
live stream, we'll
figure out how to get
them to you later.
But anyone in the room,
feel free to get up, get
some snacks.
I won't feel insulted.
I'll be really happy, actually.
So.
JORGE CUETO: Tina is
the co-founder and CEO
of Brandless, which is an
e-commerce startup that's
looking to shake things
up in the industry
by offering high quality
products at a really
affordable price point.
Great to have you, again.
TINA SHARKEY: It's
awesome to be here.
JORGE CUETO: Can you tell us
a little bit about Brandless
in your own words.
TINA SHARKEY: So Brandless--
my co-founder, Ido
Leffler, and I,
we were sort of feeling
like modern consumption
was just very, very broken.
And that meant that
if people really
understood what things cost
versus what they pay for them,
they'd be, in his words,
rioting in the streets.
I don't know that I
thought people would
be rioting in the streets.
But that there was
just this perception
that better had to cost more.
And it actually really doesn't.
And so when we
founded Brandless,
we were really trying to--
at this very high level--
try and make sense
of consumption.
There was a sense that there
were the haves and the have
nots.
And that people
couldn't actually
find what they were looking for,
shop the values they believed
in, whether it was their dietary
values, like, I'm gluten free.
Or I'm kosher.
Or I'm vegan.
Or I like to eat organic.
Or with their belief systems.
I don't want animal testing.
I want non-GMO.
I want certain
foods, certain things
that I reach for every
day to sort of live up
to my value system.
If, in fact, they were to use
that as their shopping filter,
they would definitely be paying
a premium for everything.
Because their value system
actually comes at a premium.
But it doesn't have to.
And so at Brandless,
at the highest level
we're trying to democratize
access to goodness,
starting with everyday
essentials, which is--
everything on Brandless is $3.
Sometimes it's two for
$3 or three for $3.
And all of our food is non-GMO.
Most of it is organic.
Tons of it is gluten free.
And all of our beauty
and our personal care,
our shaving gel, our
shampoo, our conditioner,
our hand creams, et cetera,
are all completely clean.
Which means in the case of
beauty and personal care,
it's free of animal testing.
It's free of SLSs, of
phosphates, of sulfates,
of synthetic dyes, et cetera.
And every single category
that we develop at Brandless,
we use that filter to
say, what really matters
in that particular category?
So for example, when we
do cleaning, our cleaning
products like our
multi-surface cleaner,
our toilet bowl cleaner, they
are EPA Safer Choice certified.
And everything that
we do is just $3.
Or two for $3 or three for $3.
But everything is
very much created
for what we consider
the modern lifestyle.
JORGE CUETO: How
do you set yourself
apart from other
e-commerce startups
have been coming up
over the last few years?
For example, the Honest
Company, which I think
is doing similar non-GMO
healthy products?
TINA SHARKEY: So as a startup,
first and foremost, we're
a community.
And we're a community
of people who believe
that everyone deserves better.
I can't really say what Honest
is doing, because I don't
know a ton about that company.
Other than to say that the
pricing structure at Brandless,
everything that we
sell is brand tax free.
So what we mean by that
is we've eliminated
all the inefficiencies
in the system
for what things cost
to produce versus what
you're paying for them.
And so I don't know
how Honest does that.
By being a community that
goes directly to the consumers
and makes things for the
people that we serve,
we are developing the products.
We're putting them into
our distribution centers.
And we're sending
them directly to you.
And so if you were to look
at national brands that
have the same quality
as ours, organic coconut
oils, organic olive oils,
organic feminine hygiene, all
the non-GMO food,
on average you're
saving 40% of brand tax
savings of national brands
of similar quality.
When it comes to things
like clean beauty,
clean personal care,
and clean hygiene,
it's as high as 300%
to 400% savings.
So I can tell you what Honest's
system is and how they do that.
But ours is really
about a community
that is connected around
a higher purpose, which
is that the doing is
what matters in life.
When you check out
at Brandless, there's
something extra in
your shopping cart.
And that's a meal that we
partner with Feeding America
to buy on your behalf
and in your honor
to feed those who don't have $3.
If you're a member of B.More,
which is our membership--
and I'll talk about
that a little later.
Because there's a surprise
coming for all of you.
We'll donate 10
meals in your honor.
And every time you
shop, we donate
two meals if you're a member.
In the first 18 weeks
of being in service
we've already donated
over 150,000 meals
to Feeding America, both to be
deployed to the disaster relief
zones in California, and Texas,
and Florida, and Puerto Rico,
where we don't
ship, but we still
are trying to do what we can.
As well as to the people
facing hunger in this country
in everyday systems
all over the nation.
JORGE CUETO: You
mentioned the brand tax.
Well, maybe a few of us here
aren't familiar with that term.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that.
TINA SHARKEY: Yes, you
wouldn't be familiar with it,
because we made it up.
And we trademarked it.
But we were trying to find
a way to actually describe
to people what we meant by that
inefficiency in the system.
So when you think
about the cost of,
let's say, in our organic
tomato sauces as an example.
So we make three different
kinds of tomato sauces.
Arrabiata, garlic,
and tomato and basil.
They're all organic.
And we work with our
partner to do that.
At that point, we then send
them to our distribution center,
or we send them to you.
That's not how most other
tomato sauce is distributed.
It's often created
at that manufacturer.
Sometimes the brand
owns the manufacturer.
Sometimes they
partner with somebody
who's making it for them.
They then have to distribute it.
So sometimes, especially in
organics and naturals market,
you can't sell directly to
a store like a Whole Foods.
You have to go
through a distributor.
And then that distributor
takes a percentage.
Then you sell it, let's
say, to Whole Foods.
And let's say it's a special
tomato sauce that you want
to have on a special shelf.
OK, well, then Whole
Foods gets their markup.
And that shelf has
a special cost.
Let's say there's already
a sauce on that shelf.
Well, you have to then remove
that sauce, potentially,
and put your sauce.
Let's say you want to
do an end cap, which
is at the end of the aisle.
Sometimes you see
those specials.
Or you have somebody out there
sampling the sauce for you.
The point is that all
of those touches--
and there's many, many,
many, many, more--
you end up paying
for that, which
is all on top of the cost
of the sauce to begin with.
So by the time that sauce
leaves the manufacturer
and ends up on your pasta, it
could be two, three, four times
what it actually costs to make.
I mean, everything is different.
But if you're benchmarking it
against a brand like an organic
of similar quality,
you're going to see,
on average, those
types of savings.
So we roll that into this
idea of brand tax free.
Which is to say
that we're trying
in every which way that we can
to eliminate that middleman.
Every product is different.
Because most products
are sold differently.
So the way a tomato
sauce gets distributed
might not be the same way--
you know, we also sell
plates, and bowls, and cups,
and knives, and
things like that.
So every system is different.
But in general, wherever we
can be completely efficient
and pass on whatever
our costs are to you
by offering everything
at one simple $3 price.
JORGE CUETO: I think something
that characterizes Googlers
even though we work
at a big company,
is that we're pretty
entrepreneurial in nature.
And people are always thinking
about what kind of product
they could potentially
go out and start making,
or what kind of start
up they'll go and found.
So maybe can you tell us a
little bit about your journey
that led you to come up
with the idea for Brandless
and how your previous
work experience influenced
your decision to start
this company in particular?
TINA SHARKEY: Yeah,
well I would say
that, first of all, the only
reason I was even keen to start
another company--
because I didn't think I
was going to do that.
I sort of liken being an
entrepreneur, especially as
a woman, to childbirth.
If you remembered what it felt
like, you would do it again.
So somehow there's
some gene in your brain
that helps you forget that.
Because I do have
two awesome sons.
So clearly that
didn't happen to me.
And I think entrepreneurship
and startups are very similar,
which is that it's
a birth process.
And it's hard.
And it's unpredictable.
But it's completely awesome.
I decided that if I was
going to do another one,
that I was going to do it
with the-- first and foremost,
with the people I wanted
to be on that journey with.
And so my extraordinary
co-founder
Ido Leffler was
somebody that I wanted
to change the world with from a
business and scale perspective.
And so we had been friends
for many years before.
We lived in the same town.
Our families were friends.
I was at the hospital when
his daughter was born.
Like, just really
somebody I admired.
And I admired his career.
And he built a bunch
of CPG companies
that had not just
great success, but also
had purpose and meaning.
And everything that I
try and do in my life
is rooted in sole
purpose and meaning.
So I said, I'm going to start
a company with this person.
And it's going to be for
profit and for purpose.
And we're not going to
do purpose as a campaign.
We're not going to do purpose as
something that's like a caboose
that we're going to jack
on to the back of it
when it's Giving Tuesday,
which it happens to be today.
I think Giving
Tuesday is amazing.
But I think every day
should be Giving Tuesday.
And that that's just a new
way of thinking about the way
we actually can live our lives.
And so that journey started
with the right co-founder.
The second thing was,
as my tour of duty
as a venture capitalist--
everyone in here, I'm
sure, in some way--
and you're a product manager.
I've been a product manager--
is about building things.
There's features.
So many of you may be
working on features.
I've worked on many.
Some of those features--
if you go through
YC, or you have
one of these other
incubation opportunities,
those features maybe
become products.
If that product
actually has a life,
that product could get
funding, potentially.
It could become a company.
So of those companies that
go from feature, to product,
to company, the rare
exception get to be brands.
Meaning something that
people understand.
It means something more
than any individual product
that they ship.
Very few of those brands
actually have the opportunity
to be category leaders.
So we're disrupting a category.
We're going to be a leader.
Or even better, are we going
to create a new category?
So in the case of an Airbnb or
a HomeAway, that was like, wow,
it's an alternative category
to the travel category.
We're going to create a new one.
I would say Uber, and Lyft,
and those companies all fall
in that category, too.
The highest order if you get
from feature, to product,
to company, to brand,
to category leader,
would be a movement.
That actually, not only are
you creating a new category,
but you're inciting
something that's
bigger than your entire company,
that's actually about something
that's about people,
and moving them,
and moving society
and culture to a place
that you want to see.
And that your
company becomes one
of the people in that movement.
But not necessarily
the only person
in that-- or the only
thing in that movement.
That ladder, as an
investor, I was always
looking for things that actually
I felt could pass through.
I wasn't interested in investing
in features or even products.
And if it didn't
have the potential
to be a brand or
a category leader,
it didn't feel
like something that
was sort of worthy of really
venture capital, which
is what it's there for.
Because it's the long term play.
So when Ido and I landed on this
idea, I felt like in my soul
this was a movement.
This was something
that was bigger
than any individual
piece of its parts.
Which leads to the
idea of Brandless.
Like, are we generic?
Are we not a brand?
No.
We are unapologetically a brand.
But we're redefining
what it means to be one.
And we're saying
we're a brand that's
based on truth, that's
based on authenticity,
and that's based on being
in direct collaboration
with the people that we serve.
So I would say
that when Google--
and Larry and Sergey
founded this company,
it was the idea of
democratizing information.
That's a big, lofty goal.
And mission accomplished.
Extraordinary.
For us-- but they're not
the only ones doing it.
But you guys are clearly
the category leaders
in a category that
didn't even exist.
Or maybe it did, but it
was very, very early.
At Brandless we're trying
to democratize goodness.
And that's this
movement, this idea
that everyone deserves better.
And better shouldn't cost more.
That's just not fair.
But it's a very hard thing
to get your brain around when
somebody tells you that this
premium that you've been
paying, you don't need to pay.
And this isn't about
going wholesale.
We're actually engineering
everything from the ground up.
But were in direct relationship
with the people that we serve.
And so in doing that, in
being a community first,
we think about
every single person
that we have the
privilege of working with.
They're members
of our community.
And so the love
letters, the notes,
the engagement that we get back
all the time, like every minute
coming into our Slack
channels and all
of our social channels--
they can't believe that
they're in conversation
with the company that
they're buying organic tomato
sauce from, or organic
feminine hygiene from,
or clean beauty from, or
other things like that.
Because our attitude is
if you want to be D to C,
direct to consumer,
then you have
to be P to P, which
is person to person.
And so everybody that
comes into our community,
we consider a member
of our community.
And everyone that's
not in our community we
see as an awesome
stranger that we
have best intentions
to hopefully bring them
along our movement.
JORGE CUETO: What do you see
as being your biggest success
of the first few months?
Because you guys just
launched in the summer, right?
TINA SHARKEY: Yeah.
We're still here.
[LAUGHTER]
So the biggest success.
I would say that 60
hours after our launch
we got this incredible
number back.
And that number was 48.
And that number has held
every single day since then.
What does that mean?
It means that we ship
to 48 states every day.
And we weren't
targeting 48 states.
We weren't advertising
to 48 states.
We would like to ship to 50.
But we can only ship in the
contiguous US right now.
That's why Puerto
Rico gets our efforts,
but doesn't get our product yet.
And Alaska and Hawaii
are not happy with us.
But we're trying.
The Canadians we really love.
But we keep asking
them to make friends
with people in
Detroit or Seattle
that have a large minivan,
because I just can't
get into Canada right now.
But the point is
that that success,
the idea that the people
that we built this for
found it, whether they
were in Tallahassee,
or Tennessee, or parts
of Texas, they found it.
And the notes that
we get back, people
who have affordable luxuries
and could choose to get and shop
anywhere but don't
have access, people
that never thought they could
have access, because they could
never afford organics
for their family,
people that have dietary
restrictions that
didn't know where
to get these things
and now can find them
at affordable prices,
and people who are
shifting their behaviors.
For example, we sell
tree-free toilet paper,
which means that no trees
were cut down or recycled
to make toilet tissue.
It's made from bamboo
grasses and sugarcane.
And so that are just
things that people love.
They didn't know that they
could actually shop their values
at affordable prices.
They didn't have
access to things.
And so some of the communities
that have shown up early--
like the gluten-free community
is a very active community
online.
And so they found us.
And that was exciting.
The vegan community,
they found us.
I think it was our first week.
We had gluten-free brownie
mix, gluten-free pancake mix,
and gluten-free
blueberry muffin mix
before we did any of the rest.
Like the regular
pancake or whatever.
And they sold out in three days.
And we were so surprised.
Like, what just happened?
And then we learn that one of
the gluten-free, very active
online groups found Brandless.
And boom, we sold out.
I mean, we're back in stock.
And we just didn't know
that those were going
to be interesting gateways.
Or for example, our first SKU
of toothpaste is fluoride free.
So we thought, you know what?
There is a growing
community of people
who believe that
there shouldn't be
fluoride in their toothpaste.
And so we know that
is a niche community.
But it's an important and
growing one, and one that's
very vocal, believe it or not.
And so we launched a
fluoride-free toothpaste.
Well, what do you know?
People like-- it blew up.
And they were using
that as a doorway
into the entire
assortment of Brandless
which has that intention
on every single bag, box,
or bottle.
So they're just
some early insights.
Because we're only--
I don't know--
18, 20 weeks in.
But those are some of the fun
nuances and stories that we're
starting to learn every day.
JORGE CUETO: Yeah,
that brings me
to the general
question of how you
think about the specific
products that you pick.
Because personally,
a lot of my friends
who are really excited
about Brandless,
it's because they're vegan.
And they're just so excited
that it's so easy for them
to access a wide variety
of vegan products
at a pretty affordable price.
When usually, I think,
vegan products either
tend to be really
hard to find, or they
tend to be expensive
relative to other products.
So this is a really
good venue for them
to reach out to and have easy
access to what they need.
So how do you think about that?
Because I know you also have
organic feminine hygiene
products and office supplies.
So it's a wide range of things.
But it seems like it's
very thought through.
TINA SHARKEY: Yeah, so
what's really interesting--
and when you go to buy shoes,
whether you buy them online
or whether you buy
them in a shop,
the likelihood is you're
probably just going,
and you're buying the
shoes, and you're done.
Whether it's a check
out at an online store
or whether it's
a physical store.
And maybe if you're buying
them from an online store,
and you don't know your size,
and they have a good return
policy, maybe you're
buying two sizes,
and you're returning one.
That's a possibility.
It's very different in
the consumables business.
In the consumables
business, it's
about the mission and the trip.
So what does that mean?
That means that
these are the things
that you reach for every day.
Whether you reach for
them in your pantry,
whether you reach for
them under your sink,
them in your laundry room,
or your bathroom,
or even your purse.
They're the things that
you consume every day.
you replenish all the time.
And so when we created this
initial assortment of products,
we were really
intentional in saying, OK,
what do people buy
52 weeks a year?
And how many
households in America--
we took a very
analytical approach.
How many households in
America buy that product?
What's the-- what we call HHPs,
the Household Penetrations.
And then we study that
based on every single thing
that people buy.
And how could we make
sure that, unlike shoes--
which is what I would call
a one and done, right?
These are the baskets
that people are building.
How can we make sure that
our shelves are stocked
with just what mattered, where
we were creating selection
and assortment, and
where there was what
we call expandable consumption.
So in the case of
snacks, for example.
Snacks is something that 98.8%
of American households buy.
And they buy them
52 weeks a year.
And if I was to ship you a
box of 10 different kinds
of snacks, whether
or not you personally
would eat those snacks,
you might try them.
If you didn't want to try
them for whatever reason,
you might bring them to work.
You might bring them
to the soccer game.
You might host a Monday
Night Football party.
There's lots of different ways
that you might eat that snack.
So that's a place where we're
launching jalapeno cheddar
quinoa puffs along with olive
oil and sea salt popcorn.
All of these are non-GMOs.
Some of these are organic.
And we're launching quinoa chips
alongside of tomato and basil
hummus puffs.
All kinds of yummy things.
And they're all--
some of them are here.
And so we're trying new things.
We're experimenting
with new things.
There are other
places where you don't
need to be paralyzed
by 50 feet of salad
dressing when the truth is you
probably just use one, two,
or three.
And so in that particular case,
our organic Italian dressing,
our organic balsamic
vinegar dressing,
and our organic
poppyseed dressing
are the three that we
know are the most popular.
And then we introduced one
that we're crazy about.
And it's a ginger dressing that
may not be everyone's taste,
but it's a way to
try new things.
And so in that category,
we're doing just what matters.
In the case of
oils and vinegars,
we launched an organic
extra virgin olive
oil and an organic
balsamic vinegar.
Might we do other ones?
We might.
But we knew that was the
most important thing to do.
In the case of the holidays,
starting in October
and taking you all the
way through the year,
we have a maple collection.
So that maple
collection is what we
call LTO, limited time offer.
And so we have the most
incredible maple twists.
Highly recommended.
Maple cookies.
Even maple lip balm, maple
coffees, and maple syrup.
The maple syrup is organic.
It's amazing.
And it's $3.
"Good Housekeeping"
just said it was
they're number one or number
two pick for stocking stuffers,
as like the best
gift of the year.
It's a beautiful
bottle, et cetera.
So looking at every single item
with that lens of just what
matters.
Not to do the
over-proliferation of choice.
But create choice where we know
that you actually want choice,
and you want trial.
Versus an area
where you're locked
into one thing or two things.
And we don't need
to create waste.
Don't create waste there.
So we're very intentional
by product, by category,
and by SKU.
How we create them.
What the formulations are.
And how we live
up to our own sort
of filter of just what matters.
JORGE CUETO: Is there some
sort of feedback cycle
with what customers want?
Do you ever get requests
for specific products?
TINA SHARKEY: Oh my gosh, yes.
So the initial assortment--
when we launched,
we launched with about
114 what we call S-K-Us.
You know, items.
And now we're
probably north of 200.
We're probably around 220.
But everything
since our launch has
been based on the
feedback of things
that people were looking for.
So there was very much
high requests for oatmeals.
And so we launched oatmeal in
September, organic oatmeals.
We launched them in packs, and
we launched them in flavors.
There was a big
request for soups.
So we just launched our organic
chicken broth, vegetable broth,
and beef broth.
What I love about our
soups as an example--
you know how you can buy in the
store those cartons of soup?
The thing I hate about those is
if I'm not cooking for my kids,
I open one, and then I
feel like I'm wasting it.
Because if I don't use the whole
carton I have to throw it away.
What's great about
Brandless is for $3
you actually get three
individual sizes.
So you can just open
them for what you need.
We also launched two for
$3 of a vegan and organic.
We have a tomato soup.
We have a butternut squash soup.
We have a red pepper soup.
They're awesome.
And they come in these
little individual boxes.
So we're very
intentional about that.
And people really wanted soup.
But we needed to do
soup the Brandless way.
And so if we can do it
the Brandless way, where
we can be brand tax
free, and we can land it
at a price that makes sense, and
it lives up to our own values,
and we love the partner who
can scale with us, we're good.
But all of that
feedback that we're
getting for our
future assortments,
we're co-creating
with our community.
JORGE CUETO: What has been
one of the biggest challenges
that you've faced
since starting out?
TINA SHARKEY: I would say
that in the context of talking
to the Google audience, both
here and in the stream--
and I'm sure this will live
on YouTube thereafter--
is that we, in being not
a feature, or a product,
or a brand, or a
company, or a category
leader, but a movement, we
really need to get big fast.
And so I would say that scaling
the company and the team--
because at Brandless,
we put people first.
And that starts with
every single person
who works at Brandless.
And so growing our
team and growing
it quickly, but with the right
people and the right filter--
you know, I say that when
I look at my own algorithm
for recruiting, I totally
weight it at the awesome human.
I don't care-- yes, of course,
you need to be qualified.
But qualifications do not
trump awesome human factor.
And so finding the
right people who
not only have the skills,
and the confidence,
and the scale to want
to be part of a startup,
but also understand scale
and how to get to scale.
And they're excited
about going to scale.
But they believe that the doing
in life is really what matters.
And they want to
make a difference,
not only by day in what
they're shipping and deploying,
but in the company
that we're building,
which we believe is going to
change the way people think
about things.
And really try and just
keep focusing on the idea
that everyone deserves better,
and that we can actually
democratize goodness with
every shipment, with every box,
with every post,
with every tweet,
and with all of our intentions.
JORGE CUETO: So with
Brandless you kind of exist
at this intersection
between commerce and then
also technology.
Do you ever feel like there's
a conflict of interest
between the two sides?
And how do you decide which side
to give in to at any one point?
TINA SHARKEY: I would say that
there's a very good chance that
might happen in the future.
But because we barely
have deployed version 1,
I would say we're in
an MVP-plus right now.
So we haven't hit
that place where
those two are in conflict.
But we definitely
want to give people
the runway to pursue
their passions
and to pursue their interests.
And so the more data
that we can play with,
the more people
are enabled to use
that data to tell the kinds of
stories that are going to help
them move their piece and
the larger piece of Brandless
forward.
So I'd say that we're
all sort of data
scientists underneath it all.
Some of us have the skills.
And some of us have the desire
to understand those insights.
So triangulating between,
who are our shoppers?
And how are they part
of our community?
What are in their baskets,
so that we can give them
more of those things?
And how can we
deploy the features
and functionality to make that
automagically possible for them
in a mobile environment?
So that we can make
it just super easy,
and mitigate click fatigue,
mitigate scroll fatigue,
and get them in and
out really fast.
So the smaller the screens
get-- as you know all too well--
the harder it is to get all
those features into one scroll.
And so given that the
universe is mobile-first,
how do you think about
that in a non-app world?
Because we weren't interested
in our first deployment
of building an app.
Because I didn't want to put
a download in front of someone
who hadn't met us yet.
But that will come over time.
So thinking about that
balance between the roadmap,
the features and functionality,
and always, always,
always putting people first.
And so that means both letting
the employees kind of scratch
their data and curiosity
itches and try things.
As well as the
users, who we want
to make it as simple, and
fluid, and easy as possible.
JORGE CUETO: In terms of
features and functionality,
you recently announced B.More,
which is an annual membership
program.
I think, in my eyes, I see it as
being similar to Amazon Prime.
So how would you say
you set yourself apart
from Amazon Prime?
And how did you decide
to start implementing
this annual membership model?
TINA SHARKEY: So
I have to say that
being compared to
Amazon Prime I take
as a complete form of flattery.
So we should have such problems.
More people have Amazon
Prime memberships
than they have
landlines in America.
So I think that
would be awesome.
Having said that,
we launched on 7-11.
Which I thought was funny.
Because it was 7-11.
Little did I know that it was
free Slurpee day and Amazon
Prime Day.
But somehow we had
already set the date.
And that was it.
But it didn't seem to matter.
Having said that,
like I said, Brandless
is building a community.
And so when we launched
B.More, our goal with B.More
was to give people an
opportunity to do more,
to get more, and to give more.
And so for $36 a year,
which, if you do the math--
and everyone in this
room I know can--
it's $3 a month.
And it's free shipping with
any B.More order, no matter--
no shipping threshold.
And so in addition,
when you join,
we give 10 meals
to Feeding America.
Every time you check
out there's two meals
that are in your
shopping cart that we
provide as priceless, as part
of your Brandless experience.
And we're just trying to
remove any of the friction
to try and make
it easy for people
to have access to
Brandless products,
to be able to afford the
things that they want,
and to be able to feel like
every day is Giving Tuesday.
In that they can actually
give more, share more,
and be more engaged.
Over time B.More
will be a platform
for partners to actually be
able to maybe share more.
So for example, on
Black Friday when
everyone else was
slashing prices,
we gave away a meditation app.
And gave-- we let people
sort of think about,
what does Brandless life mean?
Because when we say
Brandless, we're not generic.
We're not private label.
We're saying, just live
more and brand less.
Don't let somebody else tell
you that you should be taller,
that your hair
should be straighter,
that your teeth should
look a certain way,
that you should shoot
the ball a certain way.
We think you're already awesome.
And just be more.
Be more of who you already are.
And so Brandless is really
about empowering people
to just sort of live
their best lives
and not have to make a
choice between what they want
and what they can afford.
Because people shouldn't
be forced to choose.
JORGE CUETO: We have
our microphone here.
And so if you have a
question, raise your hand,
and we can get the mic to you.
AUDIENCE: What percent
of your products
do you have to take a loss on
to get that $3 price point?
And then as you--
I don't know much about how
the distribution process works.
But I assume you have a
limited number of warehouses.
Or I don't know if you can
contract through other people's
warehouses or how that works.
But as you grow, can you bring
the cost of those products
below to actually make
a profit or whatever
on those $3 products?
TINA SHARKEY: So the thing
that will blow your mind
is that the answer is zero.
There's not a single
product that we
are underwriting at Brandless.
Not one.
Now, having said that,
there's different margins
on different products.
But because you're not--
it's not like shoes where
it's a one and done.
You're buying a basket.
Because you are
finding the things
that you reach for every day.
And so it's a blended
margin for sure.
But there's not a single product
that we are losing money on,
If that's the question.
In terms of
distribution centers,
right now we have
distribution centers
in California and
in the Midwest.
And that enables us to sort
of try and do two days or less
wherever we serve in
the continental US.
And we'll be definitely
scaling that as we grow.
And so we're working
with partners
who can help us do that.
Because we are in the
consumables business,
it's not like you can just
go to any place that's also
packing shirts, shoes, and--
clearly I'm obsessed with shoes.
But it's a different
kind of distribution
when you're packaging up
grocery-like items, even
in the non-perishables space.
But we definitely will
be able to scale that.
We are not shipping directly
from our manufacturers.
Because like I said,
nobody buys one item.
People buy baskets.
Because when you go on
Brandless, you'll see
it's the things that
you reach for every day.
And usually a better
version of that.
JORGE CUETO: There's a question
related to that in the Dory.
How do you select suppliers
behind Brandless products?
What fraction of the products
come from small businesses
versus large corporations?
Does Brandless plan to
source more products
that are produced locally
or at least in the US?
TINA SHARKEY: So that's
a fantastic question.
We have very, very strict and
sophisticated sourcing policies
and strategies.
Because we never want to be to
the point of that small shop.
We never want to have
our tomato sauce produced
in someone's kitchen.
Not to suggest that the
formulation can't come
from a fabulous recipe there.
But we kind of want to be--
I wouldn't say the smallest
customer, but one of those.
Because we want to be
able to expand and grow.
We also make sure that the
partners that we work with
live up to all of our standard.
So organics, non-GMOs,
et cetera, et cetera.
And that all the certifications
that we put on the label
and tell you about
that product has
passed through all of the QA
that they have to go through.
And so all of the
partners are very much
put through that filter
and that standard.
In addition, we try
and source as much
as we can here in the US.
And I would say the
majority of the assortment
is developed here.
But there are cases
where, for example,
our pastas, our organic pastas,
and our organic olive oils
come from Italy.
And so we are sourcing
outside of the US.
But it is our desire to
do as much as we can here.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: So I think I
see a very strong value
proposition for users who
actually have restrictions.
Like my sister is
allergic to gluten.
So having that wide
variety is really exciting.
So I'm thinking for the
consumer who actually doesn't
have a lot of restrictions,
or who doesn't really
necessarily care about
whether something
is gluten-free or non-GMO.
Pound for pound, are
you actually cheaper
than similar competitors?
TINA SHARKEY: Pound for pound--
so it's a fantastic question.
Which is, yes, for
those affinity groups,
the gluten-frees, the
vegans, et cetera,
we have extraordinary
products at very fair prices.
But also there's
not a single person
in this country that
couldn't benefit
from the on average
40% brand tax
free savings on national
brands of equal quality.
So our organic peanut
butters, our organic oils,
our organic sauces.
If you're comparing
those to organic products
at a retail location, you're
paying on average 40%,
sometimes 200% more.
So the quality is extraordinary.
And there's savings
across the board.
And you shouldn't have
to pay more for that.
One thing I failed
to say, and this
is relevant to everyone
in this room and everyone
on the livestream--
but I know this is going to
be on YouTube for the public.
So I can't give away the code.
But tomorrow when you
get your perks email,
we provided a special
code for all Googlers
to get 33% off of B.More.
So that you can have
it for your families.
And that you can always get
Brandless in your homes.
And that's for every Googler
across the continental US.
So definitely please tell
your lunch mates, your cube
mates, people you
see in the hallway,
people you see on
campus, and your friends
across the community.
Brandless is only going to be
a community if the community
helps us build it.
So we really wanted you guys
to be able to participate
in that way.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
TINA SHARKEY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you can tell us--
and it's not confidential
information, of course--
the most capital intensive
part of your business.
TINA SHARKEY: Because
we have over--
we'll have by the end
of the year probably
like 250 products.
And then we'll be
growing to more.
Definitely securing
the inventory,
putting the inventory into
our distribution centers
and turning that is something
that we're very, very aware of.
But because sales
are great, and--
we're in the
nonperishable business,
but we're turning those
things all the time.
But because we're
a startup, and we
went from literally
a 100% cold start,
we are doing everything
from scratch.
So we're building everything
for the first time.
So it's not like
we're optimizing
our web site, or our servers,
or our data, or anything.
We're creating it.
The other thing
about Brandless is
that we are completely
vertically integrated.
Meaning that from the
label, to the photography,
to the packaging, to
the everything that you
see it Brandless,
whether it's on Facebook,
or on Pinterest,
or on our website,
or in any setting, everything
we create ourselves.
And so we're also
a content company.
Because we're creating all
of this content about how
to use it, how to share
it, recipes, all of that.
And we're doing that
all from scratch.
So there's an investment
in building out the company
and building out
all of the systems,
and all of the stories, and
all of those pieces and parts
of making Brandless
a community that you
want to participate in.
JORGE CUETO: Another
question from the Dory.
How do you compete
effectively with incumbents
like P&G, Unilever, et cetera?
And how do you overcome
consumer's emotional attachment
to loved brand?
TINA SHARKEY: I
love that question.
The question is really--
I'll take it in two parts.
The first question is, how do we
compete with Unilever and P&G,
or the-- let's call
those the incumbents
and the installed base.
We're not trying to compete
with P&G and Unilever.
Because they don't have any
direct consumer relationships.
So those companies,
their customers
are stores, or what
we call channels.
So whether it's Amazon, a
virtual store, a digital store,
or a physical store, they
don't have any direct consumer
relationships.
So we're not really
competing with them.
Because we're
building a community.
And they're really
suppliers to their channels.
In terms of the second
part of that question,
is for the beloved brands--
this stat, especially
for those in the room,
might come as a big
surprise to you,
which is that, of the top
100 CPG brands in America
last year, 90--
which by my math, is 90%--
were in decline.
So the problem is that the
millennial or perennial--
perennial meaning the mindset of
that new consumer irrespective
of their age--
doesn't want to buy the
brands they grew up with.
There's a loss of trust.
There's an openness to wanting
to meet companies who actually
people want to do business
with, who believe are socially
responsible, who believe that
they are listening and living
their values, and that are
transparent in the way in which
they operate.
So we're reimagining what
those relationships can be.
And there are people that
love their toothpaste
or love their toilet paper.
But when you think about the
amount of toothpaste and toilet
paper that is consumed in
this country every day--
it's a very, very big country.
And everybody-- at
least I hope everybody--
is using toilet
tissue of some sort
and brushing their teeth
at least once-- but
recommended three
times if you were
going to go to the
American Dental Association
and look at their
best practices.
So there's a lot of opportunity
to build new relationships
and introduce new products
and new ways of buying them.
AUDIENCE: So obviously
there's a ton
that goes into starting a
company, from getting people
to fill all the jobs
that need to get done,
to looking for funding,
and just setting yourself
for a successful--
setting yourself up for
a successful launch.
Can you talk about the
journey from the day
you had the idea to the
day you actually launched?
TINA SHARKEY: Yeah, so the
journey of incubation--
so Ido and I met.
We both were doing
different jobs.
I was running Sherpa Foundry,
and I was a venture partner
at Sherpa Capital.
And he was the founding CEO of
Yoobi, the stationary supply
company that gives back, and
Cheeky, the tabletop company
that makes dishes,
and plates, and bowls
all sold at Target and
around the country.
And probably many
other companies
that he was developing
with his partners.
And we said, we have to
do something together.
So that was probably maybe
even two years before--
if not longer--
before we actually
decided to start to think about
what we could do together.
At the time that we
sat down and said,
let's incubate this,
and let's brainstorm--
from the time that we
actually launched the company,
we probably incubated
it for maybe a year
or a year and a half
before a friend, who
was a venture
capitalist, said, wait,
you're incubating something?
We would love to see that.
And this turned out to be a
very sophisticated late stage
and early stage investor,
Jeff Brody at Redpoint.
And he said, I want to
seed fund this company.
Because I know you.
And I believe in you.
And I believe in
what you're doing.
But even if I don't believe
in what you're doing,
I believe in you.
And when you're
funding a seed company,
it's really about
investing in the people.
Because you're going
to learn, and pivot,
and do lots of things before you
actually launch that company.
So once we secured
this seed funding,
I knew that I had to
transition out of my day job.
And so I replaced
myself and said,
OK, I'm going to be
the CEO of the company.
Because I was like
the acting CEO.
And Ido was the acting chairman.
But we were still doing
all these other things.
And we hadn't made any
commitments to launching it.
Or we hadn't taken
any capital yet.
Once we started to do
that, we said, OK, well,
what are the things that
we have to learn and prove.
To your question of the
margin, can we actually
source these things
at this price point?
Can we create a UI and
UX for the packaging,
which had never really
been done in CPG,
where everything that we do
has the attributes that matter.
And the way in which we label
things, and the way in which we
communicate the values
and the attributes
of every single
product, could we
create a system
that would scale?
Once we felt like
we could do that,
we started to recruit
the right people who
actually had the world-class
expertise to join our team.
And then once we
started to do that,
and we realized that we felt
like we had a runway, that we
saw the path to actually
bringing this to market,
then Redpoint said,
you know what?
We want to lead the series
A. And so once that happened,
I said, OK, I'm going to shift
and be the full time CEO,
raise that funding,
and then really begin
to recruit the team.
But up until that
point, even though we
knew our name was
Brandless, we were
operating under a code name,
which is a little-known story.
Actually "Entrepreneur
Magazine," I think,
wrote about that,
which was funny.
They thought that was
really interesting,
which is that we operated
under a faux name.
Because we didn't want to tip
our hand to the industries
that we might be disrupting.
And so until we
raised the series A,
we were operating
under a faux name.
We had a faux LinkedIn.
We had a faux website.
We had faux business cards, faux
email addresses, everything.
Because we were in sort
of supplier conversations,
to make sure--
and we didn't want
to sort of tip
our hand to what we
were actually doing.
But then once we
raised the series A,
then we came out as Brandless.
We relaunched the web site.
Not the commerce site,
but the marketing site
while we were building it.
And then we started recruiting
the actual scale team.
Engineering, product,
merch, everybody.
Marketing, et cetera.
And we were off to the races.
We then knew that we were
going to launch in July.
And we didn't really
need to raise yet.
But some folks had
heard about our launch.
And so some of those folks
are actually Google and NEA.
Google Ventures,
not Google Alphabet.
So Google Ventures and
NEA came to us and said,
we're very excited
about what you're doing.
We know you're launching in,
like, three weeks or whatever.
It was very, very tight.
But we really believe in it.
And we want to be a part of it.
And so we raised our series
B before we ever launched.
And in fact, we announced
the launch and the series B
on the same day.
So that was kind of crazy.
And then we launched on 7-11,
on Slurpee day and Amazon Prime
Day.
Who knew?
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: From the time the
idea was conceptualized,
did the idea or your execution
stay on the same track?
Or you had to pivot?
TINA SHARKEY: That's
a great question.
No, we actually--
it's remarkable.
I haven't talked to Ido.
But we stayed on the
exact same track.
I haven't mentioned that to Ido
recently, that, like, can you
believe that our
first business plan,
everything we thought we
were going to do, we did.
And in fact, funny story was
that we started under embargo
going to talk to the media
around the March time
frame for the July launch,
which is really a long time
to be under embargo.
And so we had this--
and we only had at the time
a PowerPoint with JPEGs.
We didn't have all--
I mean, the products
were being developed.
But we didn't have
the products with us.
So we would go in,
and we would talk
to these journalists,
many of whom
we knew, because
we've been doing--
had relationships from
other companies, whatever.
And I would tell the story.
And we would tell them about
these incredible products.
They're organic.
They're non-GMO.
They're this.
And-- and then we'd wait
like, three, two, one.
They're all $3.
And at that moment then
we would go silent.
And the journalists
would all say to us,
like, you've got to be kidding.
Get out of here.
Stop horsing around,
da, da, da, da, da.
They were like, stop
wasting our time.
We're like, no.
They're really all $3.
Like, we swear.
In fact, that's not true.
Some are two for $3.
Some are three for $3.
And so once they kind
of processed that idea,
and then we got them the
samples under embargo.
They were all like, how quickly
can I get it for myself?
Because they loved it.
So then Ido called me up about
two weeks before the launch.
And he said, I'm mad at you.
And I said, what do you
mean you're mad at me?
He said, we never recorded
all of those meetings.
And on July 12
everyone will know.
And we can't do that same story.
I said, you know what?
It's not too late.
And so our creative director Jen
Tank and I said, you know what?
We have two weeks.
So we put an ad on Craigslist.
And we said, we're
looking for some actors
to come to a food tasting at
a startup in San Francisco.
That's all we told them.
And the reason we
wanted actors was
because we were on
such a tight budget
that we were hoping that
actors would more likely have
good expressions on their faces
if we tried this PR thing.
But we didn't-- they didn't
know what we were doing.
And we did the exact same
thing, except a little--
they actually got more
than the journalists.
Because they had
more than JPEGs.
We took them into our
generic conference room.
And we just put the food
out, just like it's here.
And then they tasted it.
And then we walked
them into this room.
And maybe we can put
this on the livestream--
I mean on the recorded thing.
The room next door to
the conference room
is what we call
the Brandless lab.
And it's kind of my version of
the Willy Wonka chocolate room.
There's no chocolate river.
Although maybe in
a new real estate
I can get that
written into the deal.
It's my fantasy to have a
chocolate river in the office.
But that's just me.
And so we showed
them everything.
And we said, all these things
you've tasted, it's all $3.
And we got the exact same
reaction of the journalist.
Like, what?
Are you kidding me?
Stop it.
That's not possible.
Da, da, da.
And then we called that,
"Awesome Strangers."
And that was the video
that we launched with,
which were these
people coming in,
tasting, and then seeing it,
and then having that reaction.
So in truth we didn't change
it from the beginning.
But we tried to--
we found that consistently
the reaction--
now, maybe if the reaction
hadn't been so good,
we might have changed it.
But the team has done
such an extraordinary job
at creating products
that people really love.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk about the $3?
How did you come to that--
TINA SHARKEY: Why $3?
That's a great question.
So I would say three reasons,
because we love threes.
So the first reason
was that, part
of the Brandless experience--
and when you go and
you check it out--
is that all of us are completely
paralyzed by what's called
now the paradox of choice.
That there is like--
you go to the drugstore.
You go to the supermarket.
And there's, as I said before,
50 feet of salad dressing.
300 sauces to choose from.
It's like, what?
Like, how do I even choose?
So part of our opportunity
was to simplify
everything including the price.
What's the difference between
$2.89, $4.62, $6.21, $4.32.
Like, it's just-- what is that?
That's like a manipulation.
So simplifying it was
one of our objectives.
Being completely easy and
transparent to navigate.
And the most important
thing is that, when
we studied the organics
and naturals market,
the sort of what we
call better for you--
organic, vegan, non-GMO,
et cetera, et cetera--
that market, if you
look at that filter, $3
is not the entry point
into that market.
And so our goal
was to what we call
blow the doors off the
front of the building
and make it much more
accessible to a much
broader swath of people.
Because our intention was
that everyone deserves better.
And better didn't
have to cost more.
And so we were very deliberate.
So it was simplification.
It was ease.
And making a much broader
addressable audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for being
here, first of all.
TINA SHARKEY: My pleasure.
AUDIENCE: And congratulations--
TINA SHARKEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --on all your success.
It seems like with the quality
of the product and also
the price point,
your product is ideal
for a low-income community.
Do you have plans to, I guess--
even with the-- well,
let me rephrase that.
It's great for the
low-income community.
However, we know that
there's a digital divide
in those communities as well.
So are the-- do you have
plans for your company
to really penetrate this
market and really reach
these customers?
TINA SHARKEY: Absolutely.
So I love that question.
Because the thing that I
was saying about-- you said,
what were some early surprises?
Because when we launched it, we
just sort of put it out there,
right?
We were like, let's just see.
If you build it, they will come.
And they did.
And so we've been hearing
from so many people
across the country that either
were living in food deserts
where they didn't have access
to organics non-GMOs, et cetera.
Or they couldn't afford
that for their family.
And for their first time,
they're able to afford that,
and they're able to
have access to it.
And the digital divide is not as
bad as the food desert divide.
And so what we're finding
is that the installed base
of mobile phones
and Wi-Fi networks,
et cetera is much
broader than the food--
and deeply penetrated
than access
to quality organic and non-GMO
foods and goods for families.
So we totally have plans.
But we're already
executing on those plans.
But we're not done.
I mean, we're going
to go to every town.
We're going to drive
what I call the United
States of Goodness tour.
And go out and
really meet people.
What I would like to do in
those communities is not so much
offer them Brandless, because
they can get that today.
What I would like to do is
meet the awesome strangers
that live there and really tell
them that they deserve better.
And really tell them that
they're already awesome.
And they shouldn't have
a sense that they're not
or that they're less than.
Because they're not less than.
And so if everyone
starts to believe
that they deserve better, and
that they're already awesome,
and that they can
afford that, maybe that
will give them more confidence.
Maybe that will create
a better conversation
at the dinner table.
Maybe that will help
people sleep better.
I mean, we have nutritionals,
a men's multi-vitamin,
a woman's multi-vitamin,
melatonin, antioxidants,
all $3.
Access to these things that they
didn't have access to before,
because they, A,
couldn't afford it,
B, didn't have a
store near them, or C,
weren't educated
about the values
of those types of products,
should be changing now.
But the most important
thing, the business
I would like to be in is
the confidence business.
Because I don't
care how you voted.
I don't care what your
socioeconomic class is.
I don't care what your race,
your religion, any of that.
You deserve better.
And if you strip away all those
layers, and all those targets,
and all the ways that we have
filtered ourselves as people--
we've forgotten
what we're here for.
We're all the same.
And this country
was built on that.
And this company was
built on the idea
that everyone deserves it.
And it's not OK
to have a divide.
Whatever's happening
in Washington,
we can change the system.
But not by going
into the system.
By building another system.
I mean, that's what this
company was built on.
And that's what our
company is built on.
We're just trying to change
a different kind of system
and trying to get
back to the values
that we actually believe
in as human beings.
We're the human being business.
And all human beings
were created equally.
And this idea that people have
to choose, it's just not OK.
But that doesn't mean
everybody has $3.
And so we want to help
those people, too.
And that's why we partner
with Feeding America.
And that's why we're
trying to teach people
about tangible acts of kindness.
Because if you just make
eye contact with a stranger,
maybe that will make
their day better.
And if that makes
their day better,
maybe they'll work harder.
Or maybe they'll be kinder
to their loved ones.
Or maybe their kids will feel
more inspired and work harder.
Who knows?
But I just think it starts with
a smile, from my perspective.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for coming here.
I really love the
idea behind Brandless.
TINA SHARKEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So since you like
threes, I have three questions.
But they're more practical ones.
So the first one
is about products.
I understand for more expensive
products like olive oils,
what we discussed, three
means low quantity.
And this potentially
could mean more waste
for packaging and
things like that.
Do you have plans to
move, I don't know,
$13 packages or something?
So that you can get
much more paper rolls,
or olive oil, or things
like that without more--
with less damage
to the environment?
And then the other two
questions are about the company.
You said you were using phony
names, and emails, and stuff.
When did you
trademark Brandless,
and other related slogans,
and things like that,
so that you didn't tip
off potential incubants?
And the third question
is about the capital,
building the company.
How much did you use
off-the-shelf components,
systems, like putting
things in cloud and things
like that, to reduce cost on
that since you're building
everything from scratch?
Thank you very much.
TINA SHARKEY: So
I'm going to try--
those are three very
unrelated questions.
So I'm going to see how facile
my brain is in the ability
to answer those.
The first question
is about, have we
thought about limited
waste in our packaging?
And the answer to that
is unequivocally yes.
You have to remember that we're
only sort of 20 weeks old.
But we are working to
create the most efficient,
just what matters packaging
and sizing whenever we can.
And so you'd be surprised.
But it's like the little things.
For example, I remember Rachel,
who's our head merchant,
and I were talking about
almonds sometime in--
I don't know, February or March.
And not only did she
source and create
this incredible
assortment of nuts,
and mixers, and all of that.
But the almond bag that
you buy, it's resealable.
And so what I love about
that is that you don't have
to eat all of them at once.
But you don't have to clip it,
or throw it away, or serve it.
You can actually reseal the bag.
So it's not just about the size.
It's about being
very intentional
and trying to make
your packaging work
as hard as it can for you.
That's the first thing.
The second thing is about--
you asked-- wait.
First you asked
about the packaging.
I know the third question
was about the deployment
of the capital.
Oh, about when we
trademarked Brandless.
So this is a funny story, too.
Which is that we trademarked
Brandless way before we ever--
just when-- even probably before
the seed, when we were just
incubating the idea.
And all of our NDAs--
people that were
working with us,
both suppliers as well
as potential recruits,
signed these NDAs.
And in the NDA it said
the name Brandless.
And not a single person
actually noticed.
Which I think is
funny, because we
said that the operating name
of the company was Dosey.
But in the NDA that
people had to sign,
it said Brandless
in the fine print.
And nobody ever said anything,
which-- we just were waiting.
Because I remember having a
conversation with the lawyers.
No, we can't put
Brandless in the NDA.
We can't disclose.
And it turned out
that we had to.
Because it was the real
company that you were in
non-disclosure with.
Nobody ever saw it.
And the third question was
about the use of proceeds,
and how we broke
down the budget,
and what we're using for
cloud computing versus--
I didn't get that last part.
Off-the-shelf components.
So that's a fantastic
question, too.
Because we could have
probably launched earlier if
we had gone with Shopify
or some sort of a turnkey.
But we really felt that in order
to build the kind of community
where we really owned
all of our data,
and that that data
belonged to our ability
to be able to create the
most remarkable experiences,
and that even if we were sort
of MVP, it was better to be MVP
and to have the kind of owned
solutions on the core data
and architecture of
what we were building.
And then when it came to
ESPs, and other places
around email scaling,
and other things
like that, that we could
work with third parties.
And we didn't have to build
those things ourselves.
But when it came to things that
were core to the experience,
those we felt we
really needed to own.
And so we made a
decision, build by license
on sort of every aperture.
And we continue to do that.
JORGE CUETO: What about
on the product side?
Off-the-shelf products that
then you brand as Brandless?
Do you do any of that as well?
TINA SHARKEY: Well,
there is no such thing
as an off-the-shelf product.
I would say that
in the case of what
is a proprietary
formulation, when
it comes to organic brown sugar,
organic flour, organic sugar,
organic oregano, there's not
a lot of formulation that's
happening there.
So it's like the packaging
and the just what matters.
When it comes to sort of
things where we are co-creating
and co-formulating
with our partners,
we look at everything
on a case by case basis.
JORGE CUETO: Great.
Well, thank you,
everyone, for coming.
It was great to have you, Tina.
TINA SHARKEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]